[Music]
this is what you get when you
open up the ui editor this is kind of
like the base
screen and so we have kind of three
columns going left to right and so the
elements panel uh has all of the various
different ui components that you can put
in your app that you can control with
the ui editor so we have you know action
button numeric inputs
plot outputs um
cards
and plots and stuff like that everything
that you would need to make a basic
uh app
more of which are coming soon
so then moving over to the right we have
the kind of just app view
and this isn't like an exact view of
your app it's more of an abstract
representation of the app
with the intent of basically being a
visual representation of the code um and
the reason why is that a lot of times
your actual app may have stuff like
dynamic ui in it and so we can't know
what that would look like so this is
basically a way of you know we're going
to put things in the right places and
we're going to give you kind of the
pertinent information
um but if you think of it kind of as a
wireframe of your app and then to the
right of that we have the properties
panel and so if we select um a given ui
component in the app like editor view
uh on the right hand side you get to see
the properties and so you see
where that given component is in the
tree of your ui so you have a grid page
uh within that you have a grid card um
and within that you have the slider so
and then you have the various settings
like input id label uh the values that
you can
change and you know all of these you
change them here and then it will update
the app for you
um
you can delete that element down with
this button
and then beneath that there's a thing
called the app preview and so this goes
back to the fact that this isn't like a
perfect representation of your app you
see like this is not a real plot it's
just kind of an abstract plot
but down here
whenever you run the ui editor
you get a preview of the app and so this
is what the app looks like actually
running and as you change stuff
um within your app
it will update down there so if we
change the
app
title content to be
shiny ui editor
when we go back here we see that it
changed here and so you can
you never have to turn off the ui editor
and restart your app to see what it
looks like we'll we'll do that
automatically for you um we'll also give
you like the logs that your app puts out
you can refresh the page in case
there's something
that changed that needs a page refresh
so yeah that's that's the very basic set
of
tools
and then there's this
uh panel up here that has a little bit
of control so say we do something like
take this move it down here and then
move our slider up to a new card over
here we say new slider
and then we say wait a minute i don't
actually like that uh we can use the
back button up here to undo that change
go back all the way to where we were
maybe we did like it we can redo
um but let's go back to that so
basically these undo and redo buttons
are there to save you if you ever
get yourself into a situation that you
don't want to be in you can always just
back up until
your app was working and looking the way
that you wanted to so we talked about
the element deletions say we want to
delete this plot called blue plot we can
just click the delete element you can
see down there it's gone
uh but once again let's put it back then
we can do things like resize
um the given component so say
right now we have this slider on the
left and the plots on the right
um and then the plot on the top is the
same size as the plot on the bottom
maybe we want to make the plot on the
top be you know maybe
a little bit more
of the given size so we can just drag
this little
sizing down here and you see the sizes
pop up
next to
stuff and it uses this thing called an
fr which we'll talk about a little bit
but that's a css unit
so basically it's a ratio of the sizes
so we're going to say
for every 0.5 units the bottom plot the
top plot is 1.5 so it's going to be
three times the size
we can stop there and go back and see
yep it made that change um and so
basically we can use this
uh to fiddle around with the sizes
say you know we're dragging this and we
see it's 200 and
305 pixels and say we really wanted it
to actually be 300 we couldn't get our
drag to be there we can mouse over that
and just
go over here and type 300
and update it that way as well i showed
it a little bit before but you can
resize these panels within this grid
by using these little handles
and then you can drag them down so put
our
settings all the way down there
um if you wanted to maybe we would use
that to make this flat bigger
um and yeah you can configure
everything to your
your heart's desire is using underneath
the hood a package called grid layout
which we are releasing kind of in
conjunction with shiny ui editor which
allows you to
make your apps uh laid out very
explicitly with grids uh so
uh when you actually look well
i guess we can talk about that later but
um
we just define where we want things to
be how big the given elements uh the
tracks of the grid are the rows and
columns of the grid and then we can just
put an element
over whatever span of contiguous rows
and columns that we want
and we know that it's going to be placed
right there we don't have to work with
kind of arbitrary restrictions such as
you know we can only have columns or we
can only have rows you can have both
basically if you can imagine it you can
put it into the grid layout we can just
add a bunch of columns if we want
and we do that by going over to these
individual column views and then you see
there's a little plus button over here
and you mouse over it says add a column
so we can do that
and then we just you know we get as many
as we want and so right now
we have this
uh
name all scrunched up over there but we
could you know make it
three of the columns um or you know
whatever
size we want to
we can resize let's see let's add a
bunch of
rows as well
you know that one here
and we're getting a little bit crazy but
we can make that there
and then we can take our
second plot make that we have this kind
of crazy
grid structure and what we could do is
say you know let's put a
text input here so we can drag a
textbook input and we're going to call
it
name field or something like that
put that there
and drag this bigger
you know we could just keep going um and
building all sorts of arbitrary
uh sizings
you know we've got
a title up here maybe we want to put our
slider all the way up here
um probably drag this down a little bit
so there's a little bit more space for
it
basically the
the world is your oyster uh so to speak
uh with what you put in this stuff so
so yeah we can we can build any any
design that you might
possibly want
as long as it can be expressed
as a grid
you can put it on here in
excel you know when you have you want to
add a column
between things you just kind of mouse up
in the little area right click here you
don't right click you just hover um and
it pops up this little interface
you can also
delete uh rows and so
it will intelligently say hey you know
you can delete this track because
everything that's within it won't
disappear so we can delete that
but say we tried to delete this track it
won't let us um and that's because
if we delete it um you know this
whole element wouldn't have nowhere to
go and so you can you can
simplify your maybe you get your layout
working the way you want to um you can
then start
uh taking out the various tracks
uh to simplify or you can leave them in
it it doesn't really matter um
you'll see that the code generated uh
for grid layout um you know it's easier
to read if you have a simpler
uh layout but
you know if you don't
it doesn't bother you you can
have your half as many columns and rows
as you
possibly want um and you can make things
look exactly how you want them to
dynamic ui output um is
very literally just like output ui
render ui
grid text card
is
when you just want to have place some
text
in the grid
and so
it basically like you see
here this title here is given is just a
grid text card and so
this is a
um
just a component that
you just want to put text somewhere you
put it in
this and so it's usually used for like
a title of your app maybe a footer
it's a pretty simple
uh
pretty simple function grid plot card uh
is somewhat so see here this is a grid
plot card
and that can be put directly onto the
grid page
and it's basically just like a shortcut
for having a card so like this is a grid
card if you were to have a grid card and
then put a plot in it it's essentially
the same thing but a lot of times
you just want to put a plot in a given
place a grid plot card does that and it
takes away some of the annoying details
of
you know you have to if you've ever put
a plot in a shiny app which i would
assume a lot of people have you know
that it starts at 400 pixels high and so
almost always you're going to want to
change that to some other value
and grid plot card is smart about that
and knows that the grid is going to give
you sizing of your plot for you it will
set those height and widths to
automatically fill the card space that
you have
and so that's kind of nice
just
allows you to skip some of the syntax
and you know instead of having to have a
card and then put a plot output in there
then make sure that the bot output is
the right sizing you can just drag
grid plot card on there and so
um that's just a you could so you could
say right now we have this plot down
here so if we delete this plot and we
put a
plain card here and we call it
just you know
this
plot
then we take a plot output
right here drag it in there
so this plot output needs to have this
plot set just flat
and you see that the height is 400
pixels we want to set this to 100
percent
um and then
you know that's effectively the exact
same thing that we get just for free
with grid card plot with plot card
another nice thing is that you notice
that all of these cards have to have
these names you know when we drag
something new into here
it says they need to name this and
that's because gridlayout needs to have
some string to identify the given areas
that you've defined on the grid
and a lot of times if you're going to
put a plot there you probably are making
that plot area the exact same
string as the plot id that you're using
to hook up your plot and so
you can get that really easily with
grid plot card you put it down there
and we just call this dist lot
say done
it automatically hooks it up to that
disc plot
argument you don't have to do that you
see in the settings
uh name of grid area is this plot and
then it automatically does that but we
could put a different output id if we
wanted to call it display2 it's going to
break because display 2 doesn't exist
but the idea is that we give as nice a
defaults as you could
want for your plot and then if you need
more control
you would just put a plot and a grid
card so you'll notice
when we put an element so say we are
going to drag
you know
the the child of
the grid layout needs to be
a grid card of some kind you know we can
directly put like the grid plot card
there because that's a grid card
so right it's a direct child but if we
take something like
uh numeric input like we had before and
we drag it here
it says you can put it on the grid
when we put it on the grid it's going to
ask us the name of this grid area so
we're going to say my merrick
but then if you actually look at this
you'll see that it it wrapped it in a
grid card
and so you still this is a full card you
can and you can put more stuff in here
if you wanted it depends i think that's
up to you the
app builder if you want to
start with
placing your cards you could basically
empty your whole app
like down to just
the grid
just super simple
you know you could say okay i want a
bunch of columns and i want them all to
be the same
size we make this
one
fr so everything is going to be
[Music]
unique like evenly sized although this
is 1.5 so we'll change it to one
one
so now we just have a grid uh
and then you could just take your cards
and put them on there
call this no plot a
position it around um and you can just
continue to do that
um
[Music]
title
header or something like that
um
if you wanted to you could continue to
do that um and then
place your stuff on there and honestly
if you wanted to you could just use the
ui editor to build this
get your layout and then go into the
code and add your stuff within those
little
uh
built out
skeleton
so it's it's kind of we're agnostic
about which way you do it
sometimes you might want the control of
putting the grid card directly but know
that anytime you put an item that is not
a grid aware item so it's not a grid
card
on it it's going to just wrap it in a
grid card for you so
you can save
a step if you want but you know maybe
you want to put titles here uh
so they say like plot okay
and then you know you'll get a title for
your card first and so you know maybe
you want to set it up that way
instead of going back and retroactively
assigning the
settings for your giving card